baignade des bretonnières une piscine au
naturel alimenté par les eaux du lac
l'eau est sous surveillance la
réglementation oblige
des prélèvements sont réalisés à la
recherche de bactéries témoin de
contamination fécale
on n'est pas à l'abri d'une pollution ça
tourne beaucoup d'eau se déverse dans le
lac
on n'est pas à l'abri d'une collection
donc c'est pour ça en faisant une un
contrôle hebdomadaire on est sûr au
moins ne pas avoir aucun souci
bactériologique on est à peu près 80
mille personnes depuis c'est notre
huitième année d'exploitation
88 personnes il n'y a jamais eu un seul
cas de maladie résidus de goudron ou
d'huile mais aussi plastique ou mousse
la surveillance est aussi visuelle pour
détecter d'autres pollutions lacs étangs
ou piscines naturelles
il y a dans la région 40 lieux de
baignade autorisée tous contrôlés par l'
agence régionale de santé la qualité de
l'eau reste excellente c'est à dire
qu'on est on est très largement en
dessous des valeurs limites de qualité
réglementaire 80% de baignade classe est
aussi excellent qu'elle
évidemment le plus haut niveau et puis
un certain nombre de baignade classé bon
le niveau le niveau inférieur donc le
bilan est très bon
une bonne note donc pour les baignades
régional à nuancer toutefois la
cyanobactérie plus communément appelées
algues bleues n'entre pas dans les
critères de ce classement
pourtant elle peut être responsable de
fermeture temporaire de baignade